with over 20 million followers Donald
Trump is the 68th most followed person
on Twitter twitter has been by far
Trump's most frequent mode of
communication to the public throughout
the 2016 primaries the general election
and as president elect Trump once
tweeted many people have said I'm the
world's greatest writer of 140 character
sentences Trump has obviously been an
unorthodox political candidate and
president-elect in the way that he
speaks and conducts himself in person
like in debates and at rallies and we've
seen him carry that over to his tweeting
taking the conventions of how
politicians use social media and
throwing them out the window
his impulsive bold bombastic demeanor
has translated verbatim to his use of
Twitter where he regularly touts his
accomplishments hastily mocks people and
doesn't always check facts Trump is said
when he becomes president that he'll
dial back the tone of his tweets and
it'll be fascinating to see whether or
not he keeps this promise as undoubtedly
we've never seen a u.s. president carry
himself the way that Donald Trump does
on Twitter it would probably be
destructive or at the very least
extremely odd to have a US president
that is constantly sending out little
daily messages on the Internet bragging
about how great he is or insulting
anyone who crosses him thus far right up
to his inauguration Trump has proven
that he has absolutely no ability to
withstand criticism and just brush
anything off even little things like
when an actor criticizes him this is the
definition of being thin-skinned he has
shown us time and again for years now
that he must unconditionally pick up his
phone and ridicule almost anyone that
says something negative about him this
is not a great trait for a president we
will have to wait and see how his
Twitter use evolves as president if it
does but I thought it would be
interesting to take a look back at
Donald Trump's history on Twitter prior
to becoming president since the
beginning of the 2016 election cycle
Trump has averaged about 11 tweets a day
and the longest he's gone without
tweeting was only for a day and a half
this past November he once tweeted 87
times in one day
his personal record on October 19th of
2016 sometimes it's just a way for him
to check in with the public and send a
little greeting like last May when he
wished everyone a happy Cinco de Mayo
and said the best taco bowls are made in
Trump Tower Grill I love Hispanics
sometimes it's a way for him to channel
his thoughts about issues that are
important to him like the 117 tweets he
has posted saying that climate change is
a hoax or is unimportant including a
total of 47 tweets saying that global
warming isn't real because it was cold
at the moment he was tweeting or his 31
tweets implying that vaccinations cause
autism or his 84 tweets suggesting that
President Obama was born in Kenya and
sometimes Trump uses Twitter as an
outlet for his signature brand of
no-holds-barred confrontational
communication that brash politically
incorrect delivery that so many of the
trumpet supporters love like the 61
times he tweeted about Rosie O'Donnell
or his hundred and fifty-eight tweets
about megyn kelly or either of these
classic tweets Mitt Romney had his
chance to beat a failed president but he
choked like a dog now he calls me racist
but I am the least racist person there
is and sorry losers and haters but my IQ
is one of the highest and you all know
it please don't feel so stupid or
insecure it's not your fault it's mostly
easy to tell which tweets are written by
Trump and which ones are written by
people who work for him data scientist
David Robinson analyzed the text from
Trump's Twitter account and found that
tweets containing messages that are
angry hyperbolic or braggadocious tweets
that use exclamation points and
emotionally charged words like crazy or
dumb tend to come from an Android mobile
operating system while the more benign
tweets things like links and photos or
positive messages come from an iPhone
it's known that Trump carries a samsung
galaxy which is an Android smartphone so
we can pretty firmly conclude
from the operating system and the
language that's used that generally
speaking tweets that say things like
Merry Christmas or thanks for coming out
to the rally today come from his social
media staff people like Brad parse kale
or dance Covino while Trump himself is
the author of tweets that convey things
like bragging and disdain Twitter also
seems to be one of Donald Trump's
favorite ways of negotiating financially
with private companies on December 6
Trump sent out a tweet about the
aircraft manufacturer Boeing saying that
their design for the new Air Force One
is too expensive Trump said Boeing is
building a brand-new 747 Air Force One
for future presidents but costs are out
of control more than four billion cancel
order even though both Boeing and the
White House said that Trump's claim
wasn't accurate Boeing stock price
quickly dropped after that tweet
a week later Trump took a shot at
defense contractor Lockheed Martin on
Twitter saying that they were charging
too much for f-35s after that tweet
Lockheed's market value dropped by four
billion dollars there is now actually a
mobile app that's been created that will
alert users when Donald Trump bad-mouths
a company so that they can sell while
the stock prices are down the developer
of the app said in a blog post this
one-of-a-kind trigger notifies you when
president-elect Trump tweets about a
publicly traded stock that you own in
real time these triggers can help you
capture moves or manage your holdings
based on the market's reaction to the
future president's remarks
the New York Times determined that about
one in every nine of trumps tweets is
some kind of insult on Twitter Trump has
used the word overrated thirty nine
times he's called someone a [ __ ] 52
times he said 55 times that someone
quote doesn't have a clue he's used the
phrase haters and losers 64 times he's
called someone a lightweight a hundred
and one times he's called someone stupid
one hundred and eighty three times he's
called someone dumb two hundred and
twenty-two times and on Twitter
is used the word loser 234 times he's
also ended 81 tweets with the word sad
followed by an exclamation point before
Ted Cruz dropped out of the Republican
primary
an analysis of Trump's tweets shows that
his twitter insults were abundantly
aimed at Republicans like when he
tweeted these two photos side-by-side
comparing his wife to Ted Cruz's wife
with the caption a picture is worth a
thousand words and during the general
election statistics show that his
twitter insults were mostly at Democrats
crooked Hillary crazy Bernie goofy
Elizabeth Warren and when Trump won the
presidency his insults towards
politicians saw a big drop-off but the
rate at which Trump insults the media on
Twitter has remained pretty constant
from rarely misses an opportunity to try
and discredit anyone in journalism who
says something unfavorable about him
whenever a news outlet runs a negative
story on him he's often quick to pull
out his phone and tweet about how stupid
or untrustworthy or unsuccessful the
news organization is according to Donald
Trump's tweets CNN is bad television
garbage and just plain dumb and most
recently fake news from his press
conference Fox News is totally biased
and disgusting MSNBC has no ratings the
BBC has zero credibility Univision might
be controlled by the Mexican government
the New York Times is poorly run and
manage the Wall Street Journal or a
bunch of dummies USA Today is a boring
newspaper with no mojo the New York
Daily News is a worthless dying loser
newspaper The Weekly Standard is failing
the New Hampshire union-leader is
failing the Des Moines Register is
seriously failing the National Review is
failing and dying and has been losing
for years New York magazine is a piece
of garbage Esquire magazine is boring
Vanity Fair is really really boring and
Time magazine quote looks really flimsy
Trump doesn't spare individuals in the
media either when they say something
negative
if you're a journalist online or on TV
questioning something that Donald Trump
has said or done there's a pretty good
chance that he'll hop on Twitter and get
his revenge against you Trump once
tweeted when someone attacks me I always
attack back except 100 times more this
has nothing to do with a tirade but
rather a way of life
according to Trump Katie Couric is a
third-rate reporter Arianna Huffington
is ugly both inside and out Barry Diller
is a sad and pathetic figure Touraine
the BLET is a truly stupid guy megyn
kelly is so average in every way George
Will is perhaps the most boring
political pundit on TV Frank Luntz is a
total loser Sherri Jacobus is a major
loser and really dumb Charles
Krauthammer is a boring dopey overrated
dummy clown John Oliver is very boring
Jon Stewart is overrated not smart and
has no talent Anna Navarro has no talent
bryant gumbel is an arrogant dumb racist
dope with no talent mika brzezinski is a
neurotic mess Chuck Todd is a real loser
with sleepy eyes that will be fired like
a dog Harry Hurt is a dummy dope Don
Lemon is a lightweight and dumb as a
rock Chris Matthews has the lowest IQ on
television and Erik Erikson is a major
sleaze buffoon total lowlife dummy Trump
once tweeted how come every time I show
anger disgust or impatience enemies say
I had a tantrum or meltdown stupid or
dishonest people shortly after winning
the election Trump claimed that he would
have won the popular vote if it weren't
for millions of illegal voters casting
ballots for Hillary Clinton of course
there's no evidence whatsoever to back
that up and when CNN senior Washington
correspondent Jeff Zeleny pointed that
out Trump attacked Zelan II by
retweeting a high-schooler Trump quoted
16-year old Seth Morton from California
who said pathetic
you have no sufficient evidence that
Donald Trump did not suffer from voter
fraud shame bad reporter
obviously pointing out that there's no
evidence that it didn't happen isn't
proof that it did happen common logical
fallacy but that aside you could tell
that this teenagers tweet wasn't
originally written by Trump because no
one was being called ugly or dumb
someone once sent a tweet to our new
president and said why do you always
insist on calling people names and
trying to taunt like a kid in a
schoolyard Trump replied only stupid
people when a president says something
people listen people act what the
president says matters and has national
and global impacts if Congress is voting
down a bill he likes is he going to go
on Twitter and start calling senators
losers if we're having a dispute with
another country is he going to tweet
that their president is a lightweight
[ __ ] this will be an embarrassment to
the United States Trump has said that
he'll be more presidential on social
media after he's sworn into office but
just a few days before his inauguration
he was on Twitter calling actress Meryl
Streep an overrated flunky because she
said something about him without even
mentioning him by name at the Golden
Globe Awards just close your eyes and
try to imagine Barack Obama or George W
Bush being so thin-skinned and reacting
that way try to picture one of those two
presidents or any other president for
that matter going on an angry
name-calling tirade just because some
celebrity said something about them it's
difficult to imagine this is the guy we
have representing the United States to
the rest of the world in charge of the
military responsible for diplomacy with
nations like Iran China North Korea when
it comes to Trump's promise to tighten
up on Twitter let's hope he does
differently than he's previewed during
his transition period and actually keeps
his word